The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Let's get going,
here.
Remember where we were?
We were trying to figure out
the structure of the atom.
At the beginning of the course,
we saw classical physics,
classical mechanics fail to
describe how that electron in
the nucleus hung together.
Then we started talking about
this wave-particle duality of
light and matter.
We saw that radiation and
matter both can exhibit both
wave-like properties and
particle-like properties.
And it was really important,
this observation of Davisson
and Germer, and George Thompson,
this observation that electrons
exhibited inference phenomena.
That is when you took electrons
and scattered them from a nickel
single crystal.
The electrons scattered back as
if they were behaving as waves.
There were diffraction
phenomena or interference
phenomena, bright,
dark, bright,
dark patterns of electrons.
Actually, that Davisson and
Germer paper is on our website.
You are welcome to take a look
at that.
It was just that observation,
coupled with de Broglie's
insight into Schrödinger's
relativistic equations of motion
that led Schrödinger to say,
well, maybe what I need to do
is I need to treat the wave-like
properties of that electron in a
hydrogen atom.
Maybe that is the key.
In particular,
maybe that is the key because
the electron has a de Broglie
wavelength that is on the order
of the size of its environment.
Maybe, in those cases,
I need to treat the particle as
a wave and not as a particle
with classical mechanics.
He wrote down this wave
equation, an equation of motion
for waves, this H Psi equals E
Psi, where we said last time we
are going to represent the
electron, our particle,
by this Psi,
the wave.
We are going to call it a wavef
unction because we are going to
put a functional form to it very
soon.
And there was some kind of
operator, here,
called the Hamiltonian
operator, that operated on this
wave function.
And, when it did,
you got back the same wave
function times a constant E.
And this constant,
as we are going to see,
is going to be the binding
energy of the electron to the
nucleus.
But then, we took a little
detour and I said,
well, let's see if we can
derive, in a sense,
the Schrödinger equation.
And that is what we started to
do.
And I am really doing this for
fun, you are not responsible for
it, but I am doing it because I
want you to see just how easy
this is.
To illustrate this,
I am just going to take a
one-dimensional problem.
I am going to let my electron
be represented by this wave,
one-dimension,
Psi of x.
2 a cosine 2 pi x over lambda.
And then I said,
suppose I want an equation of
motion, I want to know how that
Psi changes with x.
Well, you already know that if
I take the derivative of Psi
with x, that is going to tell me
how Psi changes with x.
And we did that last time.
And then I said,
well, I want to know the rate
of change of Psi with x.
I am going to take the
derivative again.
I have the second derivative of
Psi of x.
And that is what we got last
time.
And then, I noticed that in the
second derivative,
and you noticed,
too, somebody said this was
recursive, that we have our
original wave function back in
this expression.
I can rewrite that whole second
derivative here just as minus 2
pi squared, quantity squared,
over lambda,
psi of x.
So far,
this is just any old wave
equation.
Nothing special about this.
This anybody could,
and had, written down before.
What is special is that
Schrödinger realized,
here, that if this is going to
be a wave equation for a
particle, then maybe this lambda
here, maybe I ought to put in
for lambda what de Broglie told
me.
And that is h over p.
Maybe this lambda here is the
wavelength of a matter wave,
so let me write this expression
in terms of the momentum of the
particle, where the momentum has
this mass m in it.
And so when he did this,
this became minus p squared
over h bar squared,
we said hbar is h over 2pi,
times psi of x.
Hey, this is getting good
because now we have a Psi of x
over here.
But then what he said was,
well, I want to write this
momentum in terms of the total
energy.
Total energy is always kinetic
plus potential.
The kinetic energy,
we said the other day,
can be written in terms of the
momentum.
The kinetic energy is p squared
over 2m-- plus the potential
energy. And I
am going to make this as a
function of x,
the potential energy.
Now, I am just going to solve
this for p squared.
p squared is equal to 2m times
the total energy minus this
potential energy.
Now, I am going to
plug this into
here right in there.
And, when I do that,
I am going to get the second
derivative of Psi of x with
respect to x equals minus 2m
over h bar squared times E minus
U of x times Psi of x.
Just simple
substitution for p
squared there.
Nothing else.
Now, I am going to do some
rearranging.
And the rearranging,
on the right-hand side,
is I am going to have only E
times Psi of x.
E times Psi of x looks like the
right-hand side of the
Schrödinger as I wrote it down.
That is good.
When I rearrange this,
I get minus hbar squared over
2m times the second derivative
of Psi of x with respect to x
plus U of x times Psi of x
equals E times Psi of x.
And now, I am going to pull out
a Psi of x here,
so that is minus hbar squared
over 2m second derivative with
respect to x plus U of x,
the quantity times Psi of x
equals E times Psi of x.
And guess what?
We've got it.
We got it because all of this
is what we define as the
Hamiltonian.
All of this is h hat.
H hat, operating on Psi of x,
gives us E times Psi of x.
This Hamiltonian,
as you will learn
later on, is a kinetic energy
operator.
This is the potential energy
operator operating on psi.
That is the Schrödinger
equation.
It is hardly a derivation.
It is taking derivatives.
It is a wave equation.
The insight came right here,
this substitution of the de
Broglie wavelength in an
ordinary wave equation.
This is the insight,
getting that momentum in there
with the mass,
making this,
then, an equation for a matter
wave.
That is it.
You just "derived the
Schrödinger equation." Easy.
Bottom line here is that the
Schrödinger equation is to
quantum mechanics like Newton's
equations are to classical
mechanics.
When the wavelength of a
particle is on the order of the
size of its environment,
the equation of motion that you
have to use to describe that
particle moving within some
potential field U of x
or U, you have to us this
equation of motion and not
Newton's equations.
Newton's equations don't work
to describe the motion of any
particle whose wavelength is on
the order of the size of the
environment.
It just does not work.
Now, just as an aside,
classical mechanics really is
embedded in quantum mechanics.
That is, if you took a problem
and solved it quantum
mechanically,
and you solved the problem,
a problem for which the
wavelength of a particle was
much, much greater than the size
of the environment,
which is the classical limit,
quantum mechanics would give
you the right answer.
In other words,
say you took some problem where
the wavelength of the particle
is larger than the size of the
environment.
That is, a problem where you
would normally use classical
mechanics.
But if you use quantum
mechanics, you would get the
right answer,
if you could solve the problem
because the equations are very
difficult.
But, in principle,
you would get the right answer.
However, if you took a quantum
mechanical problem,
that is, a problem where the
wavelength of the particle is on
the order of the size of the
environment and you used
classical mechanics,
well, you won't get the right
answer.
Because classical mechanics is,
in a sense, a subset.
It is contained within quantum
mechanics.
It is a limit of quantum
We have to learn a new kind of
mechanics, here,
this mechanics for the motion
of waves.
Now, for a hydrogen atom,
we have to think of the wave
function in three dimensions
instead of just one dimension,
here.
And so we are going to have to
describe the particle in terms
of three position coordinates.
Usually you use Cartesian
coordinates, x,
y, and z.
But this problem is solvable
exactly if we use spherical
coordinates.
How many of you had spherical
coordinates before and know what
we are talking about?
Not everybody.
If I gave you an x,
y and z for this electron in
this atom, where the nucleus was
pinned at the origin.
If I gave you an x,
y and z coordinate,
you would know where that
electron was.
But, alternatively,
I could tell you the position
of this electron using spherical
coordinates.
That is, I could tell you what
the distance is of the electron
from the nucleus.
I am going to call that r.
That will be one of the
variables.
I could then also tell you this
angle theta.
Theta is the angle that r makes
from the z-axis.
That is the second coordinate.
And then, finally,
the third coordinate is phi.
Phi is the angle made by the
following.
If I take the electron and drop
it perpendicular to the
x,y-plane and then I draw a line
here, well, the angle between
that line and the x-axis is the
angle phi.
Instead of giving you x,
y, and z, I am just going to
give you r, theta,
and phi in spherical
coordinates.
And now, this wave function is
also a function of time,
and I will talk about that a
little bit probably next time.
So, that is the wave function
that is in some way going to
represent our electron.
I haven't told you exactly yet
how Psi represents the electron,
and I won't tell you that for
another few days.
Question?
No.
I actually thought this was the
way the book set it up.
I may have it backwards.
I think this is the way our
book sets it up.
It won't make a difference in
any of the problems we solve
here.
But, in general,
if you are given a problem to
solve, you are going to have to
look and see how they define
their coordinate system.
Actually, somebody else asked
me that the other day.
Now, what we have to do is
actually set up the Hamiltonian
for the hydrogen atom.
That is, we have to set up the
Hamiltonian specifically for the
hydrogen atom.
And we have to set it up in
terms of spherical coordinates,
r, theta, and phi.
And when we do that,
and we are not actually going
to do that, that is what the
Hamiltonian looks like.
Actually, this is in three
dimensions, and so if I were
doing it in the x,
y, z, what I would have here is
a second derivative with respect
to y, plus a second derivative
with respect to z.
That is what it would look like
in three dimensions in Cartesian
coordinates.
But when I transform from
Cartesian coordinates to
spherical coordinates,
an exercise that takes five
pages, and everybody should have
that experience once in their
life, but maybe now is not the
right time for that experience,
you do get this.
And essentially,
the Hamiltonian is a sum of
second derivatives with respect
to each one of the coordinates,
because essentially this term
is a second derivative with
respect to r.
This term is a second
derivative with respect to
theta.
This term is a second
derivative with respect to phi.
That is the specific
Hamiltonian.
These are all kinetic energy
operators, as you will learn
later on.
And then there is this term
here, U of r.
This U of r,
what is that?
What is U(r)?
Potential energy.
It is the Coulomb potential
energy of interaction.
It is isotropic,
meaning it is the same at all
angles.
The only thing it depends on is
the distance of the electron
from the nucleus.
It only depends on r.
It doesn't depend on theta and
phi.
So, that is the Schrödinger
equation for the hydrogen atom.
It is a differential equation,
second-order ordinary
differential equation.
In 18.03, you are going to
learn how to solve that.
In 5.61, or 8.04 I think it is,
in physics, in quantum
mechanics, you are going to
solve that.
You can do that.
It is not hard.
But what do I mean when I say
solve?
What I mean is that we are
going to calculate these Es,
these binding energies,
this constant in front of the
psi.
That is called an eigenvalue,
for those of you who might know
something already about these
kinds of differential equations.
This E is the binding energy of
the electron to the nucleus.
We are going to look at those
results in just a moment.
And the other quantity we are
going to solve for,
here, is psi.
What we are going to want to
find is the actual functional
form for the wave functions.
That, we can get out of solving
this differential equation.
The actual functional form for
psi.
The functional form is going to
be more complicated than what I
wrote here, but we can get that.
We will look at that in a few
days from now.
And do you know what those wave
functions are?
They are what you studied in
high school as orbitals.
You talked about an s-orbital,
p-orbital, d-orbital.
Orbitals are wave functions.
That where they come from,
orbitals, from solving the
Schrödinger equation.
Now, specifically,
orbitals are the spatial part
of a wave function.
There is also a spin part to
the wave function,
but for all intents and
purposes, we are going to use
the term orbital and wave
function interchangeably because
they are the same thing.
Question?
We are going to get to that in
just a moment,
and if you think I don't answer
it then we will go back to it.
We are going to solve this.
And this equation is going to
predict binding energies,
and it is going to predict
these wave functions in
agreement with our observations,
and it is going to predict that
the hydrogen atom is stable.
Remember when we tried to
predict the hydrogen atom using
classical ideas?
We found it lived a whole
whopping 10^-10 seconds.
Not so when we treat the
hydrogen atom with the quantum
mechanical equations of motion.
Let's write down the results
for solving the Schrödinger
equation.
And the part I am going to
concentrate on today is these
binding energies.
And, on Friday,
we will talk about the wave
function, solving the
Schrödinger equation for those
wave functions.
What does the binding energy
look like?
Well, the binding energies,
here, coming out of the
Schrödinger equation look like
this, minus 1 over n squared
times m e to the 4 over 8
epsilon nought squared time h
squared.
m is the mass of the electron.
e is the charge on the
electron.
Epsilon nought is this
permittivity of vacuum we talked
about before.
This is a conversion between
ESU units and SI units.
h is Planck's constant.
Planck's constant is
ubiquitous.
It is everywhere.
What we typically do is we lump
these constants together.
And we call those constants a
new constant,
the Rydberg constant,
R sub H.
And so our expression is equal
to minus R sub H over n squared.
The value of R sub H is equal
to 2.17987x10^-18 joules.
That is a number that you are
going to use a lot in the next
few days.
But what you also see,
here, is an n.
What is n?
Well, n is what we call the
principle quantum number.
And its allowed values are
integers, where the integers
start with 1,
2, 3, all the way up to n is
equal to infinity.
Well, let's try to understand
this a little bit more by
looking at an energy level
diagram again.
I am just plotting here energy.
Here is the zero of energy.
Here is the expression for the
energy levels that come out of
the Schrödinger equation.
When n is equal to one,
that is the lowest allowed
value for n, binding energy is
essentially equal to minus the
Rydberg constant.
**E = -(R)H**
But our equation says the
binding energy of the electron
can also be this value because
when n is equal to 2,
well, the binding energy now is
only a quarter of the Rydberg
constant. It is higher
in energy.
When n is equal to 3,
well, the binding energy of
that electron to the nucleus is
a ninth to the Rydberg constant.
When it is equal to 4,
it is a sixteenth.
When it is equal to 5,
it is a twenty-fifth.
When it is equal to six,
it is a thirty-sixth.
So on, so on,
and so on until it gets n equal
to infinity.
When n is equal to infinity,
then the binding energy is
zero.
When n is equal to infinity,
the electron and the nucleus
are no longer bound.
They are separated from each
other.
They don't hang together when n
is equal to infinity.
Now, this is rather peculiar.
This is saying that the binding
energy of the electron to the
nucleus can have essentially an
infinite number of values,
except it is a discrete number
of infinite numbers of values.
In the sense that the binding
energy can be this or this or
this, but it cannot be something
in between, here or here or
here.
This is the quantum nature of
the hydrogen atom.
There are allowed energy
levels.
Where did this quantization
come from?
It came from solving the
Schrödinger equation.
When you solve a differential
equation, as you will learn,
and that differential equation
applies to some physical
problem, in order to make that
differential equation specific
to your physical problem,
you often have to apply
something called boundary
conditions to the problem.
When you do that,
that is when this quantization
comes out.
It drops out of solving the
differential equation.
What are boundary conditions?
Well, remember I told you in
the spherical coordinate system,
r, theta, phi?
Well, phi sweeps from zero to
360 degrees.
Well, if you just went 90
degrees further,
so if you went to 450 degrees,
you really have the same
situation as you had when phi
was equal to 90 degrees.
What you have to do in a
differential equation,
which usually has a series as a
solution, is that you have to
cut it off.
You have to apply boundary
conditions.
You have to cut it off at
degrees.
Because otherwise you just have
the same problem that you had
before.
This is a cyclical boundary
condition.
And it is that cutting it off
to make the equation be really
pertinent or apply to your
physical problem,
that is what leads to these
boundary conditions,
mathematically.
That is where it comes from.
That is where all the
quantization comes from.
Now, let's talk a little bit
about the significance here of
these binding energies because
somebody asked me about it
already.
When the electron is bound to
the nucleus with this much
energy, we say that the electron
is in the n equals 1 state,
or equivalently,
we say that the hydrogen atom
is in the n equals 1 state.
We use both kinds of
expressions equivalently.
When the hydrogen atom or the
electron is in the n equals 1
state, we call that the ground
state.
The ground state is the lowest
energy state.
The electron is most strongly
bound there.
The binding energy is most
negative.
And the physical significance
of that binding energy is that
it is minus the ionization
energy.
Or, alternatively,
the ionization energy is minus
the binding energy.
It is going to require this
much energy, from here to here,
to rip the electron off of the
nucleus.
The binding energy here is
minus the ionization energy.
That is the physical
significance of it.
Now, did you ask me about the
work function?
Okay.
The work function is the
ionization energy when we talk
about a solid.
That is just a terminology,
that is historical.
When we talk about ripping and
electron off of a solid,
we call it the work function.
When we talk about ripping it
off of an atom or a molecule,
we call it the ionization
energy.
And the other important thing
to know here is that when we
talk about ionization energy,
we are usually talking about
the energy required to pull the
electron off when the molecule
or the atom is in the lowest
energy state,
the ground state.
That is also important.
But our equations tell us we
also can have a hydrogen atom in
the n equals 2 state.
If the hydrogen atom is in the
n equals 2 state,
it is in an excited state.
Actually, it is the first
excited state.
The electron is bound less
strongly.
It is bound less strongly,
and consequently,
the ionization energy from an
excited state hydrogen atom is
less because the electron is not
bound so strongly.
And, of course,
we could have a hydrogen at n
equals 3, n equals 4 and n
equals 5, any of these allowed
energy levels.
Not all at the same time,
but, at any given time,
if you had a lot of hydrogen
atoms, you could have hydrogen
atoms in all of these different
states.
Now, the other point that I
want to make is that this
Schrödinger result,
here, for the energy levels
predicts the energy levels of
all one electron atoms.
What is a one electron atom?
Well, helium plus,
that is a one electron atom or
a one electron ion.
Helium usually has two
electrons, but if we pull one
off it only has one left,
so it is a one electron atom.
Lithium double plus
is a one electron atom because
we pulled two of its three
electrons off.
One electron is left,
and that is a one electron atom
or an ion.
Uranium plus 91 is
a one electron atom.
We pulled 91 electrons off,
we have one left,
and that is a one electron
atom.
The Schrödinger equation will
predict what those energy levels
are, as long as you remember the
Z squared up here.
For hydrogen,
Z is 1, and so it doesn't
appear.
But Z is not one for all of
these other one electron atoms.
Where does the Z come from?
It comes from the Coulomb
interaction.
That potential energy of
interaction is the charge on the
electron times the charge on the
nucleus, which is Z times e.
That is where the Z squared
comes from.
We have to remember that.
Now, how do we know that the
Schrödinger's predictions for
these energy levels are correct,
are accurate?
Well, we have to do an
experiment.
The experiment we are going to
do is we are going to take a
bulb here, pump it out,
and then we are going to fill
it up with molecular hydrogen.
And then in this bulb,
there is a negative and a
positive electrode.
What we are going to do is
crank up the potential energy
difference between those two so
high until finally that gas is
going to ignite,
just like that.
And we are going to look at the
light coming out.
And what we are going to do is
we are going to disperse that
light.
We are going to send it through
a diffraction grating,
essentially.
And that is like an array of
slits.
What you are going to see are
points of constructive and
destructive interference.
But in the constructive
interference,
you are going to see the color
separated.
There is going to be purple,
blue, green,
etc.
The reason is that the
different radiation,
the different colors have
different wavelengths.
They have different
wavelengths, then they have
slightly different points in
space at which constructive
interference occurs,
and so the light is dispersed
in space.
We are going to analyze what
the wavelengths of the light
that are being emitted from
these hydrogen atoms are.
See, the discharge pulls apart
the H two and makes
hydrogen atoms.
We have to do this by taking a
diffraction grating.
The TAs are going to give you a
pair of diffraction grating
glasses.
You are supposed to come and
look at the discharge here.
You can see it.
I will turn it a little bit for
those of you on the sides here.
And we will see what we see.
If you cannot see the lamp,
you are welcome to get up and
move around so that you can see
it.
Can you do this light,
too?
This one over here,
sir.
Can you move this one away?
If you look up at the lights in
the room, you can see the whole
spectrum, because that is white
light.
I am going to turn the lamp
over here so that you can see
this a little better.
The spectrum that you should
see is what is shown on the
board.
If you look to the right of the
lamp, here, you should see a
purple line.
The purple line is actually
very light, so only if you are
up close are you going to see
the purple line.
You can see the blue line very
well.
That is very intense.
The green line is also very
diffuse.
Again, only if you are close
are you going to be able to see
the green line.
And then, the red line is very
bright.
And now I am going to move this
over here so you have the
opportunity to see it.
Again, you are welcome to get
out of your seats and move
around so that you can,
in fact, see it.
What you should be seeing,
hey, interference phenomena
works.
Useful pointer.
What you should see,
depending on which one of the
constructive interference
patterns you are looking at,
there should be a purple line,
there should be a blue line,
very intense,
purple is weak,
green is rather week,
and the red is very intense.
What is happening,
here?
Well, what is happening is that
in this discharge,
there is enough energy to put
some of the hydrogen atoms in a
high energy state.
And we will call that state E
sub i,
the energy of the initial
state.
Actually, that is an unstable
situation.
That hydrogen atom wants to
relax.
It wants to be in the lower
energy state.
And what happens is that it
does relax.
It relaxes.
The electron falls into the
lower energy state,
but, because it is lower
energy, it has to give up a
photon.
And so the photon that is
emitted, the energy of that
photon has to be exactly the
difference in energy between the
energy of the initial state and
the final state.
That is the quantum nature of
the hydrogen atom.
The photon that comes out has
to have that energy difference
exactly.
And, therefore,
the frequency,
here, of the radiation coming
out is going to correspond to
that exact energy difference.
And, for the different
energies, for the different
transitions, you are going to
have very specific values of the
frequency of the radiation or
the wavelength of the radiation.
For example,
some of those hydrogen atoms in
this discharge have been excited
to this excited state,
which we will call B.
The energy difference between B
and this ground state here is
small.
Therefore, we are going to have
some radiation that is low
frequency because delta E,
the difference in the energy
between the two states is small.
And then there are going to be
some hydrogen atoms that are
going to be excited to this
state, the A state.
And, relatively speaking,
that energy difference is
large.
There are going to be some
hydrogen atoms that are going to
be relaxing to this ground
state.
And when they do,
since that energy difference is
large, the frequency of the
radiation coming off is going to
be high.
Or, correspondingly,
the wavelength of the radiation
coming off is going to be low
because the wavelength is
inversely proportional to the
frequency.
And, likewise,
for this transition we are
going to have some long
wavelength radiation emitted.
Well, let's see if we can
understand specifically the
spectrum, here,
in the visible range for the
hydrogen atom.
What I have done is to draw an
energy level diagram again.
Here is the energy of n equals
1, n equals 2,
n equals 3, etc.
Here is the n equals infinity,
up here.
It turns out that this purple
line is a transition from a
hydrogen atom in the n equals 6
state to the n equals 2 state.
That blue line is a transition
from n equals 5 to n equals 2,
the green line is a transition
from n equals 4 to n equals 2
and the red line from n equals 3
to n equals 2.
Notice that since this energy
difference here is small,
this line has a long
wavelength.
Since this energy difference is
larger, this line has a shorter
wavelength.
All of these transitions that
you are seeing in the visible
range have the final state of n
equals 2.
Now, how do we know that the
Schrödinger equation is making
predictions that are consistent
with the frequencies or the
wavelengths of the radiation
that we observe here?
Well, we have got to do a plug
here.
This is the frequency that we
would expect.
It is the energy difference
between two states over H.
Here is the initial energy.
Here is the final energy.
We said that the Schrödinger
equation tells us that the
energies of the state are minus
R sub H over n.
For the initial energy level,
it is minus R sub H over n sub
i squared. We plug
that in.
For the final energy level,
well, it is minus R sub H over
n sub f,
the final quantum number
squared.
We plug that in.
We rearrange some things.
And then this is the prediction
for the frequency.
I said that this level right
here is the n equals 2 level,
so we will plug in the two for
the final quantum state.
And so this is then the
prediction for the frequencies
of the radiation to the n equals
2 level.
You just plug in n equals 6,
n equals 5, n equals 4,
n equals 3.
And you know what?
The frequencies that are
predicted match what we observe
to one part in 10^8.
There really is precise
agreement between the results of
the Schrödinger equation and
what we actually observe in
nature, therefore,
we think it is correct.
And there are no experiments
that cast any doubt,
so far, on the Schrödinger
equation.
Now, the set of transitions
that we just looked at are these
transitions.
Plotted here is another
energy-level diagram for the
hydrogen atom.
Here is the n equals 1 state,
n equals 2, n equals 3,
n equals 4.
And we looked at all the
transitions that end up in the n
equals 2 state.
This set of transitions.
It is called the Balmer series.
Now, the n equals 2 state is
not the ground state.
There is a transition from n
equals 6 to n equals 1,
the ground state.
It is this one right here.
But, you see,
that is a very high energy
transition.
Actually, this transition,
from n equals 6 to n equals 1,
is in the ultraviolet range of
the electromagnetic spectrum.
And so you cannot see it with
the experiment that we did,
but it is there.
And then, of course,
the hydrogen atoms that relaxed
to n equals 2,
well, they actually eventually
relax to n equals 1.
And there is a transition
there, it is over here,
n equals 2 to n equals 1.
But, again, that is a high
energy transition.
It is also in the ultraviolet
range of the electromagnetic
spectrum.
And so all of these transitions
that end up in n equals 1 are in
the UV range.
They are called the Lyman
series.
All the transitions that end up
in n equals 2 are in the
visible.
They are called the Balmer.
n equals 3, the Paschen,
is in the infrared.
Brackett is in the infrared.
Pfund is in the infrared.
And so we cannot see these
easily.
Now, these are named for the
different discoverers.
The reason there are so many
discovers is because these are
all different frequency ranges.
Different frequencies of
radiation require different
kinds of detectors.
And so, depending on exactly
what kind of detector the
experimentalist had,
that will dictate then which
one of these sets of transitions
he was able to discover.
But not only does this work for
emission, but this also works
for absorption.
That is, we can have a hydrogen
atom in the ground state,
a low energy state.
And if there is a photon around
that is exactly the energy
difference between these two
states, well,
that photon can be absorbed.
If that photon is a little bit
higher in energy,
it won't be absorbed.
If it is a little lower,
It has to be exactly the
difference in the energies
between these two states.
Again, that is the quantum
nature of the hydrogen atom.
And now, if you are calculating
the frequency for absorption,
what I have done here is I have
reversed n sub i and n
sub f.
This is 1 over n sub i squared
instead of 1 over
n sub f squared,
which was the case in emission.
And I have reversed this so
that you get a positive value
for the frequency of the
radiation absorbed.
We will have two different
equations for absorption and for
emission.
So, those are the Schrödinger
equation results.
I forgot to announce that there
is a forum this evening from
5:00 to 6:00.
You should have signed up in
recitation.
If you didn't,
and still want to come,
send us an email and come.
And we need the diffraction
glasses back as you are exiting.
See you Friday.